[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUSTAVO FLORES: Hi, everyone.
My name is Gustavo Flores, and
I'm a customer engineer here
at Google Cloud.
DANIEL FUENTES: And I am
Daniel, also a customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
GUSTAVO FLORES: Welcome back
to the Google Cloud Technical
Guides for Startups, where we're
creating a series of videos
for technical enablement to
help startups to start, build,
and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud.
In our previous episode,
we shared with you
how you can get started with
Compute on Google Kubernetes
Engine.
Today, we're moving on to
Compute with Google Compute
Engine.
We're going to kick
off by covering
what is Compute Engine?
Following that, I'll be going
over some common Compute Engine
configuration you
may want to modify.
Then we'll have a
demo of Compute Engine
where we'll do the following--
show source code in Cloud Shell,
create an instance template
for your instances,
create a managed instance
group for your template,
deploy an application
to the instances running on
the Manage Instance group,
and put a load balancer
in front of the group
so that we can access
the application.
Then were going to review
a customer success story.
So what is Google
Compute Engine?
Compute Engine is an intuitive,
and flexible, simple at scale,
and secured compute service
that lets you create and run
your applications on Google
Cloud's global infrastructure.
Let's talk flexibility.
There are six
different VM families--
three within the
general purpose,
and three that are optimized
for specific types of workloads.
General purpose VMs are
ideal for a wide variety
of applications like web
serving, databases, and image
processing, and come
in flavors optimized
for either cost or a balance
of price and performance.
Workload optimized VMs
include compute, memory,
and accelerator
optimized options
for your most
demanding applications,
such as SAP Hana and high
performance computing.
You can achieve
even greater savings
through taking
advantage of Spot VMs.
Spot VMs are affordable
compute instances
suitable for batch jobs and
fault tolerant workloads.
Google Cloud Spot VMs guarantee
higher minimum savings
and more predictability in
pricing for spot instances
compared to other
cloud providers.
Let's talk security.
Google Cloud and
Compute Engine are
designed to be secure by
default. For enhanced security,
you can leverage Shielded VMs.
Shielded VM features
include verifiable integrity
with secure and measured boot.
Secure boot helps
prevent malicious code
from being loaded early
in the boot sequence.
Measured boot ensures the
integrity of the bootloader
and kernel, and boot
drivers to guard
against malicious
modifications to the VM.
vTPM Exfiltration Resistance--
you can validate your guest VM
pre-boot and boot integrity
using vTPM technology, which
is compatible with trusted
computing group TPM 2.0
specifications.
Trusted UEFI firmware--
trusted firmware
is based on the Unified
Extensible Firmware Interface,
or UEFI 2.3.1, which
replaces legacy BIOS
subsystems and enables UEFI
secure boot capability.
Tamper evident
attestations-- gain insight
into the integrity
state of Shielded VMs
with tamper evident attestation
claims available in Cloud
Logging and Cloud Monitoring.
These integrity measurements
help identify changes
from the healthy baseline of
your VM and current runtime
state.
Live migration and patching--
keep your virtual
machines instances
running even when a host
system event occurs,
such as software or
hardware updates.
You can define IM
policies and permissions,
and you can set these
policies and permissions
that constrain all
new Compute Engine
instances to use
Shielded VM disk images
and have vTPM and integrity
monitoring options enabled.
You can shield existing
VM images, too.
Transform your existing
VMs into Shielded VMs
that run on Google Cloud,
bringing verifiable integrity
and exfiltration resistance
to your existing images.
With Google Compute
Engine and Cloud TPU,
SenSen delivers highly scalable
SaaS AI based solutions
across the globe.
SenSen's platform
analyzes and fuses
data from different IoT
devices to deliver insights
across multiple industries.
They said, "With Compute
Engine and Cloud TPU,
SenSen can spin up VMs
and configure TPU clusters
on demand with minimal effort.
An expanding capacity or
extending functionality
is fast and easy."
DANIEL FUENTES: I'm
going to demonstrate
how to create a
Compute Engine managed
instance group to deploy
a simple web application.
Docker will be used to
build the container images
and deploy them in
our virtual machines.
We're also going to expose our
application to the internet
by using an external
HTTP load balancer.
Our sample application
is a simple guestbook,
where visitors can submit
messages and clear them.
We can perform these steps by
both using the Google Cloud
SDK in the Cloud Shell or
using the Google Cloud console.
Before we get to
deploy our app, I
will use Cloud Shell to
clone the GitHub repo
and use the text editor
to show you the code.
You can find the
link to the GitHub
repo in the video description
if you want to follow along.
Let's click the
Activate Cloud Shell
button at the top of the
Google Cloud console,
and we see the Cloud Shell
session open inside a new frame
at the bottom of the console and
display a command line prompt.
Let's use this terminal to
enter the git clone command
and clone the repo.
Cloud Shell comes with
a built-in code editor
that we'll use to read the code.
Launch the Cloud Shell editor by
clicking the Code Editor button
on the toolbar of the
Cloud Shell window.
Now, let's use the left hand
pane to navigate to the code
by clicking on the CP100
folder, then App folder,
and select the app.py file.
As you can see in
this Python script,
Flask is used for handling
HTTP requests for publishing
and clearing messages,
and [INAUDIBLE]
is used to save the entries.
We also have a Docker file
containing all the commands
to create the images
that will be used
to run our Docker container.
I am now going to show you how
to create an instance template.
Instance templates
are a convenient way
to save a virtual machine's
instance configuration
so you can use it later to
create a virtual machine
or a group of virtual machines.
Let's navigate to Compute
Engine using the left-hand pane
and click Instance Templates.
Click Create Instance
Template, and it is now
time to enter our
desired configuration.
Let's give it a simple name--
Guestbook Server Template.
Under the Machine
Configuration section,
we can see virtual machines are
classified by machine family,
series, and machine types.
For our application,
let's select
a general purpose E2
medium, which we can see
has two vCPUs and
4 gigs of memory.
Under the Boot Disk section,
we can click the Change button
to select the operating
system and its version
and the disk type and size we
want for our virtual machines.
Let's add our
startup script, which
will install Docker, build the
image, deploy the container,
and expose it internally.
Our individual machines
don't need an external IP
because we will expose the app
to the internet using a load
balancer, so let's specify
None as the external IP.
And finally, let's click Create.
Now that we have
our template, let's
use it to create a
managed instance group.
Managed instance groups
lets you operate apps
on multiple identical VMs and
make your workload scalable
and highly available.
You can take advantage
of automated services,
including autoscaling,
auto healing, multiple zone
deployment, and
automatic updating.
From the instance
template section,
expand the Action menu next to
the Guestbook Server Template
and click the Create
Instance Group button.
We now see the configuration
options for our group of VMs.
Let's give this group a simple
name like Guestbook Server MIG.
And we can now decide
if we want our VMs
to be deployed in one
or multiple zones.
We will keep this in
the US Central 1a zone.
Notice we can configure the
autoscaling mode and policy
and minimum and maximum number
of VMs, autoscaling metrics,
auto healing, and other aspects
of our managed instance group.
Let's go ahead and click Create.
Now, if we navigate to
the VM instances menu,
we're able to see all the
individual machines that
are part of our
managed instance group.
Let's go ahead and check that
Docker is running correctly
via SSH.
Click SSH under
the Connect column,
corresponding to
the only instance
in our group in the Instances
list to SSH in the new window.
We'll use the command sudo
systemctl status docker.
In the resulting
output we can see
the container Engine
is active and running
a container as intended.
Before creating
our load balancer,
we need to create
an ingress firewall
rule applicable to
the group of VMs
being load balanced to
allow health checks.
Let's use Cloud Shell
to create this rule.
Notice the two source
IP ranges and protocol
needed to allow health checks.
Now, let's create
a configuration
by selecting the back
end services input
box and click the Create
a Back End Service button.
Let's give it the name
Guestbook Back End,
and let's choose Guestbook
Server MIG instance
group as your back end.
Enter 80 for the port number.
Our back end requires us
to create a health check,
so traffic is only directed
to healthy machines,
so let's select the
Health Check Input box
and click the
Create Health Check.
I will name this Basic
HTTP Health Check and leave
the default values.
Let's select our newly created
health check and click Create.
Now, let's review the front
end default configuration.
And we can see the
protocol will be HTTP.
An ephemeral IPv4 IP
address will be assigned,
and port 80 will be used.
Everything looks good, so we
can click on the Create button.
Let's review some of our
load balancer details
by clicking on the Guestbook
HTTP LB in the load balancers
list.
And we're now able
to use this IP
address to use the web
application running
in our managed instance group.
Let's use the browser
to visit the application
by copying and pasting the IP
address and port in the address
bar.
And here it is--
our simple guestbook
application.
Now, let's leave a short
message in our guestbook--
Hello, Google Cloud.
And we're set.
We deployed our
guestbook application
to our managed instance
group and exposed
it using a load balancer.
GUSTAVO FLORES: And
if, after this session,
you cannot get enough of Compute
Engine and are keen to find out
more, check out the
suggestions here and the links
in the description box below.
You can read up
on Compute Engine.
You can check out the
Google Cloud Drawing
Board on Compute Engine,
or you can try our Qwiklabs
on Compute Engine.
In our next episode, you'll be
learning about Google Cloud's
global network.
It will cover VPC networking,
firewall rules, load balancers,
a demo where we'll configure
the network for the booking
application you saw earlier.
Finally, another
customer success story.
Thank you, and we'll see
you in the next video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]